- Say hi to Taylor.
(audience cheers)
- The winner.
The winner.
- I know.
- The winner.
The winner.
The winner of American Idol is.
- He's literally only said
that to so many people.
We're two of them.
That's so cool.
- Good to see you guys.
- Is it, I found out something
new that I did not know.
I didn't know that you were originally,
they maybe almost had you as a judge.
- Yeah, originally when the
producers, Nigel and Ken--
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Were setting up the show.
They had heard me on the
radio here in Los Angeles
and they thought that I might
fit the panel to be up there
with whoever else was already on.
I guess Simon was already on board
and I don't know who else at that point.
And I was like, "Well wait a minute.
"I would love to audition to be the host."
And so I auditioned
eventually to be the host
and I got the job.
So I'm happy to still have the job.
- I know, that's incredible.
I just, I was like, what would it be like
if you initially were one of the judges?
- See, the problem is I'm like
in auto hosts mode all the time.
So I don't know that I'd be
able to sit behind the desk
and just give feedback,
I'd want to do that.
Then toss the commercial,
welcome back, how are you?
You know, all the--
(Kelly and audience laughing)
All, and that would be too much.
- Are you like this in life,
like when you're with family--
- Kelly Clarkson.
- Or like on a date you're just like,
wait, I'm sorry, I'm trying not--
- On a date, good evening, how are you?
We would like to have
the nachos followed by,
I think, would you like the fajitas?
Matter of fact, let's have
the beef and chicken fajitas
and we'll be right back
after we use the bathroom.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- No, so I have a question.
So did you always know
'cause it's such a, it's a job
where I think a few have
really excelled as much as you
and like Dick Clark.
Like there's--
- [Ryan] Thank you.
There's few that have gotten that status
to where it's just like,
"Oh my god, that's like such
a pop culture icon, right?"
So there's very few.
- Thank you.
- So that's job well done.
(audience cheers)
But also like, what
were you like as a kid?
Did you always wanna
do something like this?
- So as a kid, I wanted to
be on the TV show "CHiPs"
as a California highway
patrol, biker policeman.
- The stache.
- Yeah, I wanted to be, you know
Poncherello or Jon Baker, one
of those guys on the bike.
So I pretended to do that in
the neighborhood on my Schwinn.
And I got the, I got from
service merchandise, a siren
and I pretended I was a CHP officer.
Well, then I realized, not for me.
So I also bought a Radio
Shack mixer when I was a kid
and I pretended to be Casey Kasem,
I'm counting down the hits
and pretending to be a deejay.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love.
Yeah, yeah.
- And when I sort of really got
into recording on cassettes,
I offered to do outgoing messages
for answering machines at the time.
So I would say to my mom,
"Should I, can I do the outgoing message
"for the Seacrest family
on the little micro tape?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or to the neighbors.
Listen, I'd love to do
the outgoing message
for the Tuckers down the street.
"You've reached the Tucker residence.
"They're not home right now,
"but after the beep you
can leave a message."
And I would try and charge them for that.
- What an interesting kid.
(audience laughs)
- [Ryan] I was a little different.
- It worked out, it worked out.
So how is Idol different now
than when Taylor and I were there?
Because it's different, obviously.
- Yeah, it's, every, the
world has evolved, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean music has evolved
in such a great way as well.
And there are--
- And these artists have
seen success from it.
- Well, they've seen the map.
So you know, they've seen you,
they've seen Carrie, they've seen Taylor,
they've seen success
stories, Jennifer as well.
And so they know that they
can really be a big star.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So now when they're
eight, nine years old,
they tell me they start
training for the audition.
So when they're of age to audition,
they've rehearsed.
- Oh my God, how old are we?
- Well we, I can tell
you if you wanna know,
I'm reminded every day I try and jump,
right here, my right knee.
But they really practice
and it's almost like a sport, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like they train for the sport
of getting to audition for Idol.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And when they get there,
they've got it down.
They're impressive.
And the judges, who are really fantastic,
you know all of them.
- Yeah.
- They're so super fantastic.
They respect each other.
They love the show.
- They're so different too.
I love how that works.
- They really want everybody to succeed
and so they work with them.
You don't get to see all
this because the shows,
the audition shows are edited,
but they really work with them to try
and get them to be their best.
- Yeah.
- And you see that and
you see their love for it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think that's what makes it magical.
- Yeah, they're very emotional too.
I think that's cool as artists
when they're judges sitting there,
but they're also those
artists and they connect.
It's nice to see that.
- It is,
yeah.
- Yeah,
'cause it feels authentic
and that's why people have loved
this show so long, I think.
We are back with the
host of American Idol,
Ryan Seacrest, everybody.
(audience cheers)
- Also sitting in with
the band all hour,
American Idol winner, Taylor Hicks,
give it up for him y'all.
- Thank you.
So to celebrate Idol turning 21
you posted this photo
of your 21st birthday.
Let's check it out, so.
- [Ryan] Oh God.
(audience applauds)
Look at those highlights.
(Kelly laughs)
- Those are not natural highlights.
- Those are great sun
(indistinct) highlights.
- So I don't know if you know
how this works anybody here
but you go and you sit with foil.
- [Kelly] Foil.
- And then they put you into
this big helmet and you--
- I don't know what you're talking about,
this is all natural.
- I don't know if anybody knows this.
But that was, yeah, that was me.
And that, what I see in that is my mother
and also my father leaning
over and the birthday cake.
I know what that is, that
is a graham cracker crust--
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Chocolate fudge bottom with
mint chocolate chip ice cream
in a cookie pan, in that pan that--
- Is this your birthday thing
that you have every year?
- It is, I love it so much.
I love it so much.
I'm not like--
- Who came up with that?
- My mother, she,
I dunno if she got it--
- Wow, that's delicious.
- From like a Julia Child
recipe or something from--
- I don't know,
but I love that your birthday thing
was in one of those Pyrex things.
It's so me, my childhood.
- It's how we grew up.
I mean I would eat nachos
out of that same pan.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- The next day.
- Pull them out of the oven, yeah.
- But that pan got, I
wish I had that pan now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- If that pan could talk.
- [Kelly] I have plenty.
(Kelly chuckles)
- Yeah, so you sometimes
talk about your mom
on your radio show, does
she like this or not?
I always ask comics about this too, like--
- And what do they tell you?
- It's all over, it's across the board.
- [Ryan] My mother--
- They like to be talked about
but they don't like to be talked about.
- Well, and which is a very
interesting thing to navigate.
So my mother and my dad,
they've been married forever.
They're wonderful--
- It's something crazy.
Like over 50 years.
- [Ryan] Over 50 years,
we're a very close family.
- Yeah, over 50 years.
- [Ryan] There they are.
- That doesn't even happen anymore.
- I know.
Don't even get me started.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So they are wonderful
and they watch and listen to everything.
Well my mother,
I will tell a story about
them on a romantic vacation
or something like this and she says,
and she likes to do the,
when she speaks to me, she's like,
"Ryan John, Ryan John,
"you don't let all of
our secrets out, do you?"
I say, "Well mother, I
mean you you're going
"on an anniversary trip, you know?"
And she says, "Well, don't, Ryan John
"don't say anything before we go.
"I don't want my fans to find me."
- Oh my God, I love your mum.
- Now mother, do you think
that they're gonna get on
a Delta flight from Atlanta
and come find you on this
island in the Caribbean?
Because they've heard me talk about it?
- She might end up a "Dateline Special."
(Ryan laughs)
If you're that hardcore.
- But it's cute because
she really enjoys it
and she really is, she's wonderful.
And she takes pictures
with people and loves,
I guess they do recognize
her 'cause she was on--
- Yeah.
- "LIVE with Kelly and Ryan"
every now and then too.
- Yeah, no, I think.
- It's great to have that.
I love that relationship with my parents.
- Yeah.
- That's great.
- I love that you have just like,
such a great support
system, that's amazing.
Like over 50 years just
having that stability
in a family--
- And yet I'm unmarried.
So I'm trying to figure--
- You know why though, you know,
hey, this was a question though.
You know why though?
I think you and I are similar
in the fact that I really do,
like from a young age, I've
always had lots of jobs.
I often wonder 'cause people ask me this,
"Oh, do you regret being so busy?"
And I'm like, I don't feel,
I think what other people
perceive as really busy.
I don't perceive as really busy.
Like I can get exhausted, you know?
And I do feel like I
could cut back, but like,
have you kind of always been nine-o?
Like do you regret being
so busy all the time?
- No, I have no regrets about it.
I love, I operate busy.
Like I do--
- [Kelly] You too.
- I do more things when I'm busy.
If I have one thing to do on a weekend,
I almost don't get it done.
So I operate like that.
- Yeah.
- And I knew, I just knew
what I wanted to do so badly
and I was lucky enough to
start chipping away at that.
And so the more I was doing what I loved,
the more I took on,
hoping that I could do
it for a longer period,
long period of time, right?
Have longevity in it,
so I don't regret that.
- No one has the kind
of longevity that you have.
Like that's incredible.
- Thank you.
I could, 30 more years,
I'd love to do this.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you will be--
- But I--
- That's, it's crazy.
(audience applauds)
It's gone by fast.
But I've gotten to a place in
my life where I don't regret.
You know, like I don't, there's
nothing good about that.
- Me neither.
Yeah.
- There's no
productivity in that.
- No one wins there.
- No one, no,
you just stay up all night
thinking about it, right.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's not worth it.
- Well, later we have a woman
who is part of your Seacrest
Studios which I've actually--
- You've been to some of them.
- I've been to, yeah.
So can you tell everybody about that?
- So, years ago I wanted to do something
for children's hospitals
and I talked to parents
and patients about their
stays in the hospitals.
And there was, in the places
I were, there was not,
the heartbeat a place for, you know,
people that were in the hospital.
Both parents and the
patients like the center,
the nucleus, and a place to escape.
And so I wanted to create that space
and I came up with this
idea of media centers,
radio and TV studios in
the center of the hospital.
- It's so cool.
- So that parents could come,
kids could come down from their beds.
If they can't get out of their beds,
they can watch the shows that happen
and the patients create the programming.
They produce the shows,
stars like Kelly Clarkson
and Justin Bieber and
whoever's on tour come by
and the patients interview the
stars and do their own shows.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we started with one and
I thought, okay, you know,
this is really great
in creating some energy
inside the walls of the hospital.
Well, now we are gonna have
14 by the end of Summer
across the country.
- It's so crazy.
(audience applauds)
- And my mom and my dad and
my sister all operate it.
And it really truly, as you've seen,
it's just a magical place where people,
patients forget why they're there.
And we've had--
- The escapism is nice.
- We've had some parents say,
"Ryan, I have to tell you my
child would come for treatment
"and fight having to go to the hospital.
"Now my child asks me,
'When do we get treatment?
"'I wanna go to the Seacrest Studio.'"
- Oh.
- And so it's really--
- Look what you did there.
- It's changed--
- To create something in usually
a negative environment.
- Hopefully, the perception,
exactly.
- And a sad environment
and just an intense one to release.
- It's changed the feeling a little bit.
- Yeah.
- That's what we're doing.
- Yeah, I think it's the
most beautiful thing.